je préfère me battre contre le le
microbe à celui qui vole plutôt que
d'avoir le vaccin oui pourquoi parce que
cela que ça c'est pas là que ça et on a
beau le dire et avoir des remontées d'un
peu partout c'est une expérimentation
mondiale 707 une personne à risque et je
suis les personnes à risque parce que
j'ai fait confiance au vaccin puisque je
suis du milieu médical d'accord donc
j'ai tous mes anciens axe un
essai
je suis aide soignante voilà j'étais
être ça qu'il faut en plus oui oui c'est
un coin mais oui mais il faut il faut
écouter les professionnels de santé il y
en a qui disent des conneries qu'on
partout mais il y en a qui disent des
vérités quoi vous avez entendu par
exemple le professeur comme la ja je
connais pas seul à 48 heures ce monsieur
qui a dit le vaccin est efficace et pour
miley médiocre c'est ce qu'il a dit il
et c'est pas un vaccin alors mettez-vous
ça dans la tête quoi c'est quelque chose
qui est expérimental tenez-vous pression
des années d'être contaminés je préfère
faire oui me contaminer mois et que mon
corps fès face son immunité fasse son
travail avec des vrais médecins qui
peuvent
prescrire avec des vrais médicaments
failli gagner de quoi faire mais si on
les bloque et comble que toutes les
informations c'est normal qu'on soit
dans ce bordel et qu'on soit enfermé toi
il ya des morts quoi il ya des mots qui
est qui géraldine chez vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec non mais après je respecte
la laisse mari madame aime à se vacciner
elle n'a pas à se vacciner elle va
travailler normalement le coc vide ou
pas d'ailleurs vous pouvez très bien ne
jamais le temps respecte je suis
maintenant
c'est la loi on respecte tout le monde
alors titre personnel je préfère me
vacciner il alors en ce moment c'est
vrai qu'il ya des gens moi je connais
une personne qui m'a dit je voudrais
attraper le coc vide là pour choisir si
je puis dire le timing il ya isabelle
qui régit qui dit moi j'aimerais bien
qu'à daniel attrape le
voyage et à la fin du mois et qui me dit
mais comme comme c'est un rhume autant
que j'attrape maintenant et qui m'a dit
est ce que tu sais comment je pourrais
entre guillemets attraper le coc vide là
maintenant après voyager quand je
voudrais c'est assez intense qui se
propage il faut savoir qu'aux pays bas y
avait un kit corona qui était vendu 32
11 euros oui oui oui le gars est dans
les urines et aux pays-bas alors et
voilà le gars était avoir été absolument
ahurissant que 3 euros 50 avec le virus
à l'intérieur donc c'est une tendance
qui se développe c'est puisque vous
étiez deux soignantes pourquoi vous avez
pas l'hôpital donner des coups de main
dans l'est dans les rayons qu'aux vives
comme ça dans les départements communes
et puis vous mettez pas de masque je
suis en invalidité 2 impose de vaccins
obligatoires
et que je ne peux pas m'occuper des
autres donc que les vaccins qui sont
obligatoires qui était obligatoire soit
disant sans danger et qu'on a du mal à
faire reconnaître qu'ils sont
kitsch et on fait pas mal de dégâts de
maladies auto immunes donc je me soigne
et je prends soin de moi alors il faut
seulement vous avez fait le vaccin
contre l'hépatite c il ya presque 11 ans
et depuis vous souffrez de maladies auto
immunes c'est ça la gent vous savez donc
vous êtes traumatisés j'en ai trois ou
quatre de maladies auto immunes ou à
cause de 500 à cause d'eux des vaccins
oui et où j'ai fait confiance aux
médecins donc la laque et c'est vrai
qu'elle a elle a eu un traumatisme
mentalement